Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, a U-Download of the book, Beating Credit Limbe, and this
is separating about 12 sections that you're going to receive a video just like this.
This is a keynote presentation on video that will just help you understand the section as
you're walking through it.
I hope that the book sections are very beneficial for you.
It will give you a clear understanding of how to deal with your line and how to move forward
from here.
Always you can contact our clinic if you have questions.
Mainly in our office we see cancer patients and chronic live patients, so that's pretty
much all I see anymore.
It is an unconventional disease, and there's many conspiracy theories of why it is, why is
that standard medicine talking about it?
I may believe in some of those different theories you may not or vice versa.
I don't know.
We just don't know.
There's a lot of unknown about Lyme disease, so we can share some of the things that we
do know.
It started in the early 70s, at least, that we know the named Lyme disease came from a Lyme
Connecticut, where a number of people started getting symptoms, and because of those symptoms
that were diagnosable at the time, they named the disease after it, so a collection of symptoms
becomes a syndrome.
It was initially a syndrome.
It was given a name of a disease in the early 80s when Dr. Bergerdorfer discovered the bacteria
that was the cause of it, and they gave him the name of the spirochete.
It is a Graham negative bacteria.
We're going to talk a lot about that through this program, and that is important, as you're
trying to kill it, and it is in the same family as each pylori, and some of the other Graham
negative bacteria.
We'll discuss that as well, because that can be a co-infection with Lyme disease.
Typically, it's beryllia, beryllia, beryllia, bacteria, and there's a number of them.
There's a number of co-infections, and my test kit that I use, I have over 100.
So that's typically how we test for Lyme, we have to test for all the co-infections as
well.
In the 2000s, though, as we're starting to recognize Lyme disease, even though the CDC
still weeks a blind eye at it, we're going to talk about what they recommend as far as
testing goes and why there's so many false negatives in testing Lyme disease.
These states today are now passing laws that are making it protective doctors that choose
to treat Lyme disease.
If you are a licensed medical doctor in most states, and if you're advertising that you're
treating critical, you are already got a target on your back.
If you are using antibiotics beyond the first month or two with Lyme disease, you've got
a huge target on your back.
The big question with some people that are maybe labeled conspiracy theorists is why in
the world would you put such a label on a doctor's back when the pharmaceutical industry seems
to have an open door to create some sort of pharmaceutical that will at least alleviate
some of the symptoms of Lyme disease?
That's what really sparks the thought of a conspiracy behind this and how it all started
possibly as a created bacteria.
That's why there's some political advantage to keeping it hush-hush.
We won't go into that in this program.
We really want to get into the different phases of Lyme disease and how to treat it because
I don't really care how it initially started, how it was created, possibly in a laboratory,
what a deal with the debilitated problem that you might be having.
In my book, there's three phases of Lyme disease and we're going to hit this very hard throughout
this whole book of this program.
There's phase one, which is the acute phase, which you really want to treat with antibiotics.
You want to catch it within its window and we'll talk a lot about that.
Phase two is chronic Lyme.
Many people think that they have chronic Lyme, but they're actually in phase three, which
is at an autoimmune stage, and that's why they can't get better.
Phase two, chronic Lyme, you can still treat with herbs and TH1 stimulants.
We'll talk about that.
When you're in phase three, autoimmune Lyme, you can't treat it that way, and that's why
people are still in the state of what this woman looks like in this picture.
They have a lot of symptoms because they're already in an autoimmune phase.
That's all due to you.
I've heard about that through this book, and it's probably much different than you hear
about anywhere else.
So read the part of the book that came with this video.
I hope you enjoyed.
I hope you start to understand a little bit different phase of Lyme as far as different aspects of
Lyme as far as how we look at it.
If you have any questions, feel free to contact our office.
Thank you much.